they now asked us to understand what's
the behavior of this function here
particularly the square root of the
function because I wasn't philosophy you
got the square velocity as the angle
that you actually shoot at as it changes
in relation to the angle of the hoop so
let's look at part two
they're interested in the limit of
velocity I see your approaches alpha now
just think for a second just don't don't
start doing algebra yet look at the
diagram look at the diagram what does
this mean as theta gets closer to alpha
right what you're doing is you're trying
to throw the ball like as close as you
can
straight the hoot does that make sense
stuck directly in the hoop okay now
therefore don't get shout out there but
what would you anticipate the answer to
be think about if you threw it up like
this is the nice kind of art that
they've got there and what will have to
change to the how hard you throw the
ball as your angle of throwing gets
closer and closer to the actual angle of
the fruit just think about it for a
minute try it intuitively have it answer
your head and then now let's think about
the algebra okay let's see if we can
confirm or not what your thought was I'm
looking for the limit as the square root
of this right as theta approaches alpha
okay there's a lot lots of bits and
pieces here so the first thing we're
going to do is I'm gonna say it will
look see how this is connected to alpha
right just this guy so I'm just gonna
think about here as theta approaches
alpha and then all sort of build the
rest of it around okay so let's think as
theta approaches alpha let's just think
about that cos squared theta business
right what happens to this guy what
happens to this guy
well just look at the way I phrased this
expression there's no problems with just
evaluating it at the limit right you see
there's no issues with doing that so I'm
just going to substitute in this is
going to be cos square alpha sorry x
1005 yes hold on TANF on Tate off let's
just sign up for a cos alpha right so
therefore one of these cosines is going
to kids are with the cosine in this
denominator right so what do I get left
with yeah I'll just run in this one side
of you left to it okay now that's what
you get on the right-hand part of this
denominator but look if you rehearse the
same argument with this what happens to
this as theta approaches alpha what does
it approach answer it approaches exactly
the same thing so I'd like you to extend
this logic and I'm going to say
therefore the limit as B approaches
alpha of the whole denominator just
think about the denominator right now
okay and I wonder if you can see why I'm
just thinking about the denominator when
I put in both pieces of the denominator
it's clearly going to attempt towards
zero very good now this is what's nice
about have you just dealt with the
pieces okay I can just say it's zero
what does I can't do that when I've got
the whole thing because you cut zero no
denominator but now that I know that
denominator is going to zero
why is that telling about the whole
fraction it's going bigger and bigger
that bigger actually it's tending
towards infinity right so therefore the
limit as future is alpha of V squared
that's the whole thing over there is
going to be infinity and so therefore
theta which is actually in the people
are interested it's RV which is also
tested today okay now I asked you before
to have a guess as to what was happening
right like what happens as the angle I'm
actually throwing at gets closer
questions to the angle of the actual
group does this
make sense right I have to throw harder
and harder to get there because magic
right if he's the hoop up here and he is
made okay if I throw at the same angle
and I throw it just kind of like I give
it a bit of a Wimpy throw right
the second knife throw what's gonna
happen it's just gonna drop down right
I've gotta throw if I throw a bit harder
it will come off at this angle but it's
going to come down because gravity is
already doing stuff to it the second I
release in fact if I want that to be a
straight line right that means it has to
be turned so hard but like it doesn't
actually experience gravity at all so
have you got a good are you okay so now
I want you to think for a second have
you applied that logic and then see what
happens what do you make of pot - the
same question they're thinking about
feet are pressure you a different angle
what angle are they looking at
yep okay so if you're throwing at pi/2
radians or 90 degrees now I wonder if
you can actually talk me through this if
you can think hard enough to work out
physically what's going on what angle am
i throwing out what does this look like
for the basketball player yes straight
up right so for example we know it's
gonna be something like this would be a
nice angle to throw okay but if you
wanted to throw it higher like cuz you
know cuz like Mark Steyn your front of
you right okay so this football you need
to get it over here so you've got to
throw it a higher angle which means
you've got to throw it harder clearly
because it's gonna make this huge it's
much bigger distance right so therefore
I'm guessing even though I'm putting in
a different values here I've predicted
you will be the same limit does that
make sense
what algebra can we use to verify that
how would you like this dress
cuz this I think is part 1 part 1 part 2
part 1 this is part 2 part 2
okay - okay so it's theater purchase
pile - I've got to think about which
part what would you like me to put it
what would you like me to evaluate just
that guy - see you want me to do the
whole denominator that's okay ah okay
sure
again because I'm just dealing with the
dog this guy's dying a little bit
because I'm just dealing with the
denominator and he has learned problems
at the particular value that I've been
given I've been asked to evaluate I'll
just give a throat plan to it she can
swim in closet plan - of course is zero
now I'm a very regular living right now
I've been to zero times anything is zero
but I want to show what's going on this
is actually going to a value right which
then becomes tribute does that make
sense in the same way you get zero
squared times ten alpha which also
becomes so therefore just like before
the denominator tends to zero which
means the whole thing tends to infinity
and you can make the same argument now
what you got to be careful because if
you are saying zero times infinity
you're comparing a number with an odd
number if you are thinking about things
behaving right like for example if I
were to compare like y equals x versus
wife is 1 on X as X approaches zero
right well what does x times 1 on X what
would you say that that's equal to Adam
approaches zero I'll just let you think
about that
I just let you think about it okay so
just be careful with it you may throw
around zeroes in fees they don't like to
behave like no one on this you